my work involves studying how protein
molecules which are the machines that
operate life how how some of them are
shipped outside of a cell so almost all
the cells in our body produce most of
the proteins that act inside the cell do
the chemistry of life but about 10% of
the proteins on average our special
proteins that have to be encapsulated
and then sent by export out of the cell
these are proteins that everyone knows
about insulin growth factors hormones
all of the proteins in your blood are
actually manufactured inside of a cell
and then have a special machinery for
their export this pathway was first
understood by using the electron
microscope to peer inside of a human
pancreatic cell and the Nobel Prize in
1974 was given to a pioneer by the name
of George Pilate who understood how the
machinery inside of the cells conveyed
molecules outside of the cell but what
he didn't understand because of the
techniques available at the time was how
this me how this these machines operate
and so when I started my career at
Berkeley I chose to study baker's yeast
which is not a traditional system to
evaluate protein secretion but they
still that's how they grow and divide
they actually secrete and assemble their
membrane using this process of secretion
and so my first graduate student one of
my first students Peter Novick and I
just developed a genetic approach that
allowed us to isolate mutations that
cripple this process and when we did so
we were able to see that yeast cells use
a process that's essentially the same as
human cells and as a result the
biotechnology industry was able to use
yeast as a vehicle for the production of
useful human proteins in fact one third
of the world supply of human insulin is
made by secretion and yeast and so what
we did which was just very basic turned
out
quite practical application